most of the times if I'm angry it means
I don't fully understand the situation I
felt like I had a bone to pick with both
my parents I was an angrier kid when I
wrote my mother's story from the fact
that she was born in France came here
when she was four got beat up as a kid
didn't speak English but I was like
going through this and thinking you know
it makes sense she is this way I just
remember this kind of very disarming
moment being like I can't be angry with
you I get it it was tough I'm sorry and
then she just like burst into tears I
think that was kind of a big
breakthrough for me as a person because
I was like huh this person that I've
like held all this anger towards my
anger came from ignorance that's been a
frame that I've tried to approach
situations and when I start feeling
angry about something I'm like what do I
not understand and that kind of helps me
defuse those things and so I think over
time that's helped me in business
scenarios and business settings make
better decisions